[Música]
segundo espacio de economía en directo
americano ya está nuevamente jorge jorge
qué bueno tenerlo acá de nuevo iniciamos
hablando por supuesto del alza en los
precios que provoca esta guerra en
ucrania así es y específicamente del
precio internacional del petróleo que el
día de hoy tocó máximos históricos desde
el 2013 en el mercado de futuros de
londres el barril de crudo brent para
entregar en mayo llegó incluso a los 111
dólares con 59 centavos en un alza del
6,3 por ciento por su parte el precio
del barril del petróleo west texas
superó los 110 dólares motivados por la
preocupación mundial del abastecimiento
energético tras la invasión rusa en
ucrania hay que tomar en cuenta que
rusia es el segundo mayor exportador de
petróleo del mundo después de arabia
saudi pero también el mayor productor de
gas natural la opep y sus pies aliados
entre ellos rusia confirmaron hoy que en
abril le añadirán 400 mil barriles
diarios de crudo a sus suministros un
modesto aumento planeado en julio del
año pasado la preocupación se centra
ahora en la incidencia de la inflación
para las economías del mundo y aunque en
américa latina' algunos países
productores de petróleo como méxico
colombia y venezuela podrían
beneficiarse por la venta a una empresa
del petróleo sus ciudadanos se verán el
efecto del aumento de los precios sobre
todo en el transporte en el costo de la
energía y probablemente los alimentos
esto es como un efecto dominó en la
economía jorge en un mundo tan
globalizado la unióneuropea expulsó el
del sistema suiza siete bancos rusos
pero no al expert bank así es la lista
no incluía este banco que es la mayor
entidad del país ni a gazprombank porque
procesa en gran parte de las operaciones
energéticas con el bloque la expulsión
del sistema fue pactada con las
potencias del g7 y será efectiva dentro
de diez días esta exposición aplica a
cualquier persona entidad y organismo
establecido en rusia y cuyos derechos de
propiedad pertenezcan directa o
indirectamente en más del 50 presidente
cualquiera de estos bancos que fueron
afectados por las sanciones yury borísov
el vice primer ministro ruso admitió hoy
que era difícil prever la magnitud y
profundidad de las sanciones
occidentales contra la economía de rusia
y eeuu anunció el cierre del espacio
aéreo a las aerolíneas
así esta decisión se suma a la que ya ha
tomado por ejemplo la unión europea y
canadá de prohibir el acceso a las
aerolíneas rusas la medida fue aplaudida
ayer durante el primer discurso del
presidente bailén sobre el estado de la
unión ante las dos cámaras del congreso
de eeuu la casa blanca reconoció que la
medida no fue fácil de adoptar porque
provocará una medida recíproca por parte
de moscú y afectará a cientos de vuelos
americanos que pasan por rusia para ir a
asia rusia ya cerró su espacio aéreo a
los vuelos de 36 países entre ellos
todos los de la unión europea y canadá
como respuesta a las restricciones que
trajo la invasión rusa en ucrania el
presidente by the end y sus aliados de
europa han prometido asfixiar la
economía rusa por su incursión militar
contra ucrania que inicia el 24 de
febrero que cumple hoy 7 días ahora
repasamos más noticias económicas en
torno a esa guerra así que si comenzamos
con el fabricante automotriz ford que
anunció que suspenderá sus operaciones
en rusia uniéndose a las medidas tomadas
por varias empresas de todo el mundo
tras la invasión de ucrania otras
empresas como general motors y harley
davison las petroleras pp y se le
tomaron medidas y las empresas
americanas de tarjetas de crédito visa
mastercard y american expres tomaron
medidas para implementar las sanciones
impuestas a rusia que impide a los
bancos rusos utilizar su red las
compañías anunciaron que vigilarán de
cerca la integridad de las redes de
pagos especialmente por posibles
ciberataques y meta la empresa matriz de
facebook anunció que va a etiquetar las
publicaciones que tengan enlaces de
medios estatales financiados por rusia
en facebook e instagram la empresa
afirma que busca detener la difusión de
propaganda rusa en sus redes sociales
apple anunció que detuvo la venta de
iphone y otros productos en rusia la
empresa dejó de exportar sus productos
desde la semana pasada y sacó las
aplicaciones de los medios retegui
sputnik de la app store fuera de rusia
la empresa de logística alemana dhl
también anunció que suspende los envíos
a rusia y bielorrusia y cómo están las
cosas como están los indicadores bueno
la mayoría de las divisas y las acciones
de los mercados emergentes asiáticos
cayeron lideradas por la rupia india y
las acciones después de que los datos
del producto interno no cumplieran las
expectativas y en europa el banco de
reduce anunció que mantendrá cerrada la
bolsa de moscú por tercer día
consecutivo por el temor a un desplome
de los principales valores por las
fuertes sanciones económicas
pobres gracias entonces por toda la
información en torno a la economía el
impacto que ha tenido esta guerra en los
números gracias ahora vamos directo
hasta parís
[Música]